NHS England saying a further 758 people
who tested positive for coronavirus have
died bringing the total number of
confirmed reported deaths in hospitals
in England to 5655 up from four thousand
eight hundred ninety seven at the same
time a Monday let's just bring you the
breakdown of how that's looking patients
aged between 23 and 102 years of age 29
of the 758 patients aged between 23 and
99 had no known underlying health
conditions families are obviously been
told yeah I was making the point at
least that a week ago we had some
encouraging news we've got that weekend
lag so that the Monday figures looked
quite promising but then Tuesday came
along and you got a spike and it looks
like we've just seen a repeat of that
yeah we have we have certainly we did
with the figures in Scotland now it
looks like we've seen the same with
those figures here in England yesterday
we reported that the increase in the
number of people dying was 367 it's
almost double that today up to 758
matters because as you were explaining
there is a lag over the weekend this is
not a number of people who have died in
the last 24 hours it's a number that is
released in the last 24 hours that the
data is collected it's sent through to a
central collection system and then it's
compiled and then distributed so
sometimes we see a discrepancy if you
start adding up the numbers from England
Wales Scotland Northern Ireland and then
you have that figure released by the
Department of Health for the National
total later in the afternoon about four
o'clock you will see there is a
discrepancy and that's because of the
way the figures are collected and then
sent to a central point which which then
puts them all together there is a delay
sometimes in how long it takes to
collect those figures and then put them
on to a general database but certainly
we have seen what we think is it's
probably acceptable to say that this is
the weekend effect we saw the same thing
happened last week so there there is a
pattern and that's usually a smaller
figure on the Monday with much larger
forgot on the Tuesday but still and I
suppose this is the critical thing this
it's still too early for the government
to look at these figures and decide
whether a lot
down a soft lockdown as it stands at the
moment needs to become much harder or
indeed it becomes looser and then start
allowing some normality to creep in they
will say certainly the messages stay at
home and save lives they don't know
whether the full impact of that lockdown
is taking place and it is being
reflected in those figures too early to
say here but we are certainly moving
closer towards that